while most of us were in lockdowns
during the pandemic reports of internet
crime skyrocketed so this morning we
want to show you how scam artists use
real people's names and photos without
their knowledge to create fake accounts
from april to june this year facebook
removed more than 1.7 billion fake
accounts from its site but it's
impossible to know how many are actually
out there our doctor tara narula shows
us how scam artists are causing big
problems for social media users
including someone very close to her
this is petty officer mike sensei and
his dog lucy but go online and it's
difficult to find mike scentsy do you
have any idea how many fake mics there
may be out there using your picture uh
too many uh
i would probably say you know five six
hundred over the different social media
platforms five or six hundred
impersonations of you
about five or six years ago he started
seeing his real name and images used on
fake social media accounts for dating
scams and other online cons do you have
any idea how many people at this point
in time have been scammed or
what they might have lost financially
how much
somebody messaged me probably about two
years ago and they said they sent over
fifteen thousand dollars of their own
money every single day i get a message
from somebody who has been you know
duped out of money or have put you know
months of their life into somebody
romantically who they thought they were
talking to and it wasn't them so i feel
bad for those people and he's not alone
one night my husband received an
instagram message from a woman in brazil
she said she was speaking with a man
calling himself ryan but later realized
something was wrong and it was the
photos were of my husband and my kids
and they were being used for an apparent
scam and earlier this month cbs news
correspondent charlie dagetta warned
someone created a fake account using his
pictures writing if you love me please
report them how easy is it to create a
fake account it's really easy it's a
little too easy issy lapowsky is chief
correspondent for the tech news website
protocol so let's pick
a username she showed us how to create
an account using just an email address
fake name and the image of one of our
cbs news producers okay and here's randy
lewis 555212 and here we are and then
gradually i'm going to build out this
profile so you want to recreate a life
how can you possibly know if your image
is being used as part of a scam a lot of
people find out because they're told
another way is to do a reverse image
search so you can see hey is my photo
showing up in any places i don't
recognize or pretending to be anybody i
don't know we did just that with an
image of my husband by going to google
images clicking the camera icon and
uploading the picture these are pages
that include the image so
here's one oh great so so my husband's
photo is being used to meet guys for
dating on top face i'm sorry to break
that news to you and while reporting
fake accounts on instagram is easy to go
up to these three dots right here
you're going to click report user and
that's it that's it
mike sensei says it doesn't always work
when it first started happening
instagram was really good about deleting
the profiles but it kind of went away
i'll report them myself and they
literally message back and say oh
they're not doing anything wrong we
can't take the profile down do you think
some of the social media platforms
should be doing more to protect people's
security absolutely everyone says just
put your stuff on private but at the end
of the day i shouldn't have to censor
myself and my social media to appease
other people who are using it in the
wrong
way instagram told us quote claiming to
be another person on instagram violates
our community guidelines and we have a
dedicated team that's tasked with
detecting and blocking these kinds of
scams and i brought a special guest with
me for this segment 60 minutes plus
correspondent lori siegel who's been
covering stories like this and saw us
report the fake instagram account with
my husband's pictures lori i have to
tell you this is so frustrating as a
mama bear protective of my husband and
my kids we actually reported this last
fake account dr cangello 11 which is not
my husband's instagram account two weeks
ago and i looked this morning it's still
up so what else can we do i mean first
of all let's acknowledge like
psychologically this is really hard when
this happens right this feels incredibly
violating so you can report it to the
ftc um i had a top security professional
a professional guy named chris hadn't
analyzed your um your husband's fake
profile and what this whoever did
the person or people behind us what they
did was they took from public face his
public facebook twitter and instagram
and created a fake instagram profile and
bought a fake number on the internet and
so people could contact him right right
there's a phone number easy to do all of
that and so what you could do right and
you heard mike say this in the piece is
you could privatize all of your social
media but
we're sitting here in public you're a
public figure he
likely relies on social media to do this
so it's a really complicated problem i
would say the next step report it to the
ftc you know you can try to ping
instagram and facebook again but it
sounds like you've already reported it
we have multiple times right yes it's
frustrating to hear it's still up okay
it is yeah that two weeks ago and it's
still up yeah i don't know what's taking
so long everyone wonders um
i'm curious how many or what percentage
of social media users do we think have
their identity stolen and used for fake
accounts good question
i mean in short a lot you know facebook
had an estimate that the fake accounts
on the platform uh represent about five
percent of its worldwide monthly that's
actually users so that's exactly right
you could say five percent okay facebook
has almost three billion users so that's
a lot then there's also research to
suggest that between five to fifteen
percent of accounts on twitter are fake
and we've all talked about this with
thoughts and manipulation and political
manipulation so it's really a large
number and from your own personal
experience it's only getting worse and
it's a really violating type of scam
we've been talking about social media
and the impact it has on kids in
particular teen girls
a few days ago i got a message from an
older woman and she said can you guys
talk about fake accounts and scammers
leaning on um the loneliness of women
yeah and is there anything that these
women who might be lonely who might have
lost their husband
and they're being approached by accounts
that they don't know if they're real and
some of them being scammed out of their
heart and of money what should they look
out for you know that's so heartbreaking
and you talk about your husband's
picture being used with your children
right and that was the worst part and i
can imagine how violating that is and i
think that's what a lot of these folks
do chris hadn't aggie the security
professional i spoke to was telling me
about obituaries and how a lot of these
scammers will go and look to see if
someone recently passed away and then
they'll target
widows online you know but but also i
think what's important to mention is um
a lot of the people that get
impersonated are people who seem
trustworthy um
veterans doctors
right military folks and those are a lot
of people who have their photos stolen i
still don't hear a solution here guys
right about about how we we can stop it
or avoid it or
i think look i i think we pressure our
tech companies to do a better job when
when you're able to report this to take
this down i think it's really it's it's
not okay that weeks later that this is
still up i think we have to educate
people educate our parents right educate
our loved ones
yeah you know don't send money to a love
interest if you haven't met them in
person or i mean you you should have
that conversation in general but you
know if you get a message from someone
asking for money you know for financial
relief call them before you terror that
is very upsetting because you were just
randomly checking david's picture and
there he is oh yeah when we were taping
this segment i had no idea and it was
these top-faced dating sites from
afghanistan and west africa and really
all of these places i had no idea oh
yeah yeah well they pick people who they
think look good
he's very handsome and so is the veteran
we had on there
not a coincidence not being
inappropriate he is very happy thank you
dr tara narula and lori siegel good to
have you both here